We've talked at length in this course about contractual breaches.
Indeed,
the majority of the cases we've discussed thus far have involved a breach of a
or a claim of breach.
Today we're going to continue our discussion of anticipatory breach.
Will do so by examining,
examining a colorful case decided by the Supreme Court of California in 1975
Taylor versus Johnston h be Taylor and his wife bred,
raised and raced thoroughbred horses in Los Angeles.
Two of those horses were mayors named Sunday slippers and sandy fork,
Elizabeth and Elwood Johnston operated old English Rancho,
a well known horse farm that provided stallion stud services.
The the plaintiffs sought to have Sunday slippers and sandy fork breed with the
Johnston stallion fleet ness ruler.
In January of 1965 the Taylors and the Johnston's entered into two contracts,
one for each mayor providing that fleet to nus.
Roula would perform breeding services in the year 1966 for $3,500 if the mayor
has failed to produce a life full,
a return breeding would be provided the following year at no additional cost.
However,
in October of 1965,
the Johnston sold the stallion to two men,
ag Pesan and Leslie Combs,
the second horse breeders at spend thrift farm in Kentucky for $1 million.
On the day of the sale.
The Johnston's wrote to the tailor's advising them of the sale and telling them
they were released from their reservations for the stallion.
That letter seemed to have been a backhanded way of the Johnston's telling the
tailors that the Johnston's weren't going to perform their promises to provide
stud services.
After the Taylor's attorney wrote back demanding performance and threatening
suit,
the Johnston's ex,
uh,
changed their tune and they explained that they had made arrangements with the
new owners to breed the tailors mayor to fleet Nass.
Roula in Kentucky,
Sunday,
uh,
slippers and sandy fork were subsequently shipped to a farm in Kentucky awaiting
the opportunity to breed
pressing and combs.
Upon purchasing fleet,
Nasrullah had sold various individuals shares that entitled the holders to breed
one mayor each season to the Sallian.
Mayor's could only breed during a five day period when they were in heat.
These periods occurred every three weeks at several breeding opportunities.
The tailors representative in Kentucky attempted to book breedings,
but each time fleet nus Roulo was already booked.
Eventually both Sunday slippers and Sandy Hook.
We're bred to a former Kentucky Derby winner.
Chateaugay.
Both mayors became pregnant,
but with twins undesirable for thoroughbred racing.
Because of this,
the tailors did not have to pay the fee for that stallion services.
The is ultimately sued the Johnston's for breach of contract.
The Johnston's cross complained for stud fees,
the California Supreme Court,
and explained that because no actual breach could take place until the time
specified for performance at arrived and because the mayor has had been bred to
another horse before,
the time from the contractual term had ended,
there had been no actual breach of contract.
By contrast,
anticipatory breach occurs when a party to a contract or Puty eight's the
contract in advance of performance being do and express repudiation is a quote,
clear positive,
unequivocal refusal to perform unquote and implied repudiation results from
conduct where the promise or puts it out of his power to perform so as to make
substantial performance of this promise impossible.
This parallels the two forms of repudiation we discussed in section two 50 of
the second restatement of contracts.
The trial court had found anticipatory breach by selling fleet us rule love.
The Johnston said quote,
put it out of their power to perform properly.
Their contracts unquote further the conduct of the Johnson's and the Kentucky
breeders to whom they'd sold pleat.
Nasrullah constituted repudiation,
but this court,
the supreme court disagreed.
It explained that when a party repudiates the other party has options,
she can treat repudiation as anticipatory breach and seek damages immediately or
she can treat.
The contract is still in force until the time of performance arrives and if
actual breach occurs,
seek remedy then,
but if the party does the ladder quote,
the repudiation is nullified and the injured party is left with his remedies.
If any in vocable at the time of performance unquote,
we might think of a repudiation as analogous to an offer to cancel that the
promise he can either accept or reject or that they offer or can retract.
Yeah.
Can you identify specific moments when the tailors repudiated the agreement
based on the facts that you've learned?
Okay.
Well,
looking at the facts,
the court found two distinct potential repudiation.
First,
when the defendants pen their letter to the plaintiff after selling fleet
Nasrullah and second,
by virtue of the defendant's failure to provide a breeding opportunity for the
mayors to the stallion,
the court determined that the ladder,
that the letter was an express repudiation,
but that because the Taylors had responded by demanding performance electing not
to treat the repudiation as anticipatory breach,
they know modified that repudiation.
It's as if they had by rejecting the offer,
blown up the offer to cancel the contract.
Next,
examining the defendant's conduct.
Once the mayors were shipped to Kentucky,
the court denied that a second repudiation ever took place.
There had been no express repudiation because neither the Johnston's nor their
agents said they would not perform,
nor was there an implied repudiation.
The defendants never put it out of their power to perform the contracts.
They merely postpone the time of performance those postponements and never went
beyond the terms of the contract.
There was thus no anticipatory breach and the court reversed as we studied in
the last class.
Restatement section two 50 defines repudiation in terms similar to those used by
the California Supreme Court of Repudiation is a statement by the obligation war
to the obligation indicating that the obligation will commit a breach.
That of itself give the obligate a claim for damages for total breech or be a
voluntary affirmative act which renders the obligation unable or apparently
unable to perform without such a breach comment be to this section explains that
to constitute a repudiation quote,
a party's language must be sufficiently positive to be reasonably interpreted to
mean that the party will not or cannot perform language that under a fair
reading amounts to a statement of intention not to perform except on conditions
with which go beyond the contract that constitutes a repudiation.
We see in Taylor that the letter the Johnston's wrote upon sale of fleet nus
ruler is a statement by the [inaudible] that falls into section two 58 this is
equivalent of express repudiation.
Did the defendant's commit any voluntary affirmative act that would render them
unable or apparently unable to perform without a breach?
Well,
probably not.
It may have been the case that fleet Nasrullah was booked every time the tail
representative tried to range a breeding appointment,
but it's not at all evidence that the defendants were unable or apparently
unable to perform.
The UCC section two six 10 similarly treats anticipatory repudiation as a
promises offered to cancel the contract that the promise he can quote for a
commercially reasonable time await performance by the repudiating party or
resort to any remedy for breach even though he's notified the repudiating party
that he would await the ladders performance and is urged retraction and in
either case suspend his own performance.
One way that the UCC prods buyers not to wait too long before deciding whether
to accept a seller's offered repudiation is that the market measure of damages
is limited under UCC section two seven 13 to the difference between the market
price when the buyer learned of the breach and the contract price.
If a buyer waits longer than is commercially reasonable,
when the seller is jumping up and down telling the buyer that the seller is not
going to perform,
then the buyer might get less than full compensatory damages because the court
may find that the buyer learned of the breach either earlier before arise in the
market price.
So what have we learned from Taylor versus Johnston?
The case provided us a clear overview of the concept of anticipatory breach.
We learned what constitutes both expressed and implied repudiation and what
options a party has if the other party to an agreement has repudiated the
contract.
We learned that a repudiation can be seen as an offer to cancel,
uh,
an agreement which can be rejected,
or,
uh,
retracted by the repudiating party.
We'll end this lesson with some historical trivia.
Fleet Ness Roula fleet rule is genealogical line went on to produce famous prize
winning horses like the triple crown winner and Disney films.
Subject secretary it,
it's not surprising.
Fleet Nasrallah was in such high demand.